Speaker 1: Consider yourself invited
to grab a membership on my website.
Join Pacman dot com, one of our primary
sources of revenue. We do an extra show
every single day for our members and you can use
the coupon code better 21 to get a discount. I was
browsing The David Pakman Show subreddit this
morning. You can find the subreddit at David
Pakman dot com slash Reddit. We are close to looks
like close to 33000 subscribers to the subreddit.
It's free. I'm selling you nothing other than a
good time. Let's look at a few interesting posts
I spotted this morning. One is, are you going
to get the flu shot this year? User Lime Guy
actually put up a poll, and the poll results an
unscientific survey of our subreddit audience.
40. I'm sorry. Let's see here. Oh, percent. I
don't even see percentages here. It looks like
it's about two thirds say yes, they are going
to get the flu shot. About one seventh or one.
About one seventh. Say no. And about a little over
that. Say, maybe I got the flu shot this year. It
felt great. It really did. I had. I think my arm
bothered me a little bit the next day. Otherwise,
no symptoms. Much, much, much more fun than the
COVID vaccination series. Let me put it that way,
I felt pretty, pretty lousy after that. Listen. In
particular, with hospitals very full with COVID.
Anything I can do to reduce the odds that I
need to go to the hospital for another reason,
or that a member of my family needs to go to the
hospital for whatever reason I'm going to do.
And so yes, I got the flu shot. I feel very
good about it. New data says you can get the
flu shot and the COVID shot very close together.
I think Kathy Griffin even posted a video or a
picture of herself getting them at the same time
extremely safe and worth doing, so I hope people
will do it. Another user says Has David ever
spoken about subreddits like Herman Cain award?
I'd be curious to know what he thinks about a
subreddit like this. I'd imagine he's not a fan,
as he doesn't seem to indulge in the schadenfreude
many seem to. In regards to the pandemic,
to this subreddit at large, what are
your thoughts on the Herman Cain award?
Is it doing some modicum of good by spreading
awareness or is the toxicity becoming a problem?
Users have gotten in touch with extended family
of the deceased harassing them, and some of the
rhetoric on the subreddit has escalated. For my
part, I'm a fan of getting people vaccinated,
but none of the aforementioned issues. Yeah, I
mean, listen, that the doxing and the harassing
family members of those who died unvaccinated
from COVID. Yeah, that's a hard no for me.
I do have no problem with and I've done it on
the show. Highlighting loud anti-vaccine voices
who told everybody not to get vaccinated
and said they weren't getting vaccinated
and then they got COVID and then they died,
not because I enjoy the fact that they died,
but because I hope that they are cautionary
tales for other people to go and get themselves
vaccinated. So to the extent that on Herman Cain
award, there is cheering and it's called Herman
Cain Award for people who may not know because
Herman Cain died of COVID, as far as we know.
And he may have gotten it at a Trump rally,
Speaker 3: although
Speaker 1: it's speculative. It's not clear that
that's actually the case, but that's that's the
reason for the name of the subreddit celebrating
the deaths. I'm not a fan of, and I've only looked
at that subreddit once and there was some toxicity
on it. I won't lie, but if we can make if the
death can become a cautionary tale and get people
vaccinated, either way, someone tragically died.
But it doesn't have to be completely in vain if it
maybe help somebody else. Another post I spotted
on the subreddit How can these folks, folks like
the teacher? David showed video of very recently
who make the claim that they don't want to put the
vaccine into their body and how it's their right,
etc. How can they also simply ignore the option
for being tested with some frequency instead?
The fact they ignore that makes it look
like they actually want to infect people.
What possible issue would they have
with COVID testing as a replacement
for getting the vaccine? What you have to remember
is that they don't want to do anything that is
under the umbrella of a mandate. So if
the problem, you're completely right.
If the problem is vaccination and you can skip
vaccination with testing, then you say, great,
I'll do the testing weekly or I'll do the testing
daily or whatever is required by my employer,
agency or whatever the case may be. It's
not really just about the vaccine. For some,
it's about the vaccine, but it's also about not
doing anything someone else tells you to do.
And so if you're being told you've got to do one
of these two things vaccine or test, it becomes
less about the vaccine and more about freedom,
liberty, I'm going to do whatever the hell I
want to do now. We've already talked about how
your freedom to do something has to be balanced
against others, freedom not to be damaged by
your actions. Conversation we've already had. But
it exposes the fact that so many people who say I
just have a problem with the vaccine also refused
to be tested or don't want to be tested shows
us it's not really about the vaccine, or at
least it's not only about the vaccine. Join the
subreddit at David Pakman dot com slash Reddit.